this is just perfect so Fox Nation uh
aired a documentary where the Nigerian
brothers who were hired by Jesse
Smollett remember the entire thing was a
hoax it was pushed on us by MSNBC and by
CNN Kamala Harris told us this proves
systemic racism Nancy Pelosi AOC they
all lied about everything but but that's
what they do they're all professional
Liars they fall for everything that fits
their narrative it's so weird every
every story that fits their narrative is
exactly perfect and when things don't
fit their narrative it's always from a
white supremacist or a misinformation
specialist it's wild
anyway Fox Nation did a documentary with
the Nigerian brothers who smilet hired
for the hoax okay and and they did this
in a funny like this is funny I don't
even know how this came to pass but here
are they're the asundario brothers here
they are walking through the events of
the hoaxed attack on Jesse Smith this is
just great
they took our beautiful bench this is
where we waited for Jesse to come before
we attack them
got here with 10 minutes to spare and we
had to plan our Escape Route to survey
the land his building is actually right
here right above the stairs that we're
going to attack a man okay that's him
let's go
gotta go get this Empire
yeah that's him that's him is that him
that's that neck standing there oh he's
moving fast come on let's get him get
that scare them smack a country
man he said what did you say to me and
then that's when I threw the first punch
at him
I held the blower because I didn't want
to hurt him of course so I made it look
real but I held it then we started
tussling moving moving around and then I
threw him to the ground I came around
with the Bleach the infamous bleach in
the hot sauce bottle poured it on his
shirt then I finally put the Rope around
his face I did not put it around his
neck I just placed it on his face and
that's when we took off
we're in The Matrix we really are in The
Matrix it's all made up it's all
nonsense and I seriously hope you
laughed or smiled at that like what is
going on here now those guys look
they're not guilty of uh of nothing
they're guilty of something right they
took the cash for the hoax and they
would have gladly got away with it but
then the whole thing fell apart
fortunately uh but it's like they're not
the true bad guys in this thing it's
Jesse Smollett and it's every Democrat
and wilkester who fell in for the hoax
and tried to use it as a political
cudgel over the rest of us right like
this proves systemic racism and all the
rest of it like oh we're gonna get that
Empire
[Music]
thank you